[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com prosecutors have dropped a
criminal case against actor Kevin Spacey
where he was accused of sexually
assaulting an 18 year old in Nantucket
Massachusetts back in 2016 and the
district attorney Michael O'Keefe said
that he was abandoning the case due to
quote the unavailability of the
complaining witness and this is
something that actually started a while
ago where the alleged victim decided to
stop testifying or participating
invoking the Fifth Amendment on the
witness stand last week
I don't really know there's a couple
different stories Pat about why this is
going on one is that the individual who
was 18 at the time was pressured in some
way that there was some some kind of
foul play or interference happening
outside of the system the legal system
up to and including he was offered money
and now he's clamming up the other
possibility is just that the attention
that this was getting and the fact that
this involved a celebrity and that there
were like helicopters following Kevin
Spacey on Nantucket when he would go for
these hearings that it just became
completely unpalatable and and horrible
for the then 18-year old and that this
was the path that he found to making
this go away as soon as possible now
regardless of which side you fall on
that once again we get to this question
of are there two justice systems here
one for the rich and one for everybody
else and I don't know whether in this
particular case that's the right
analysis
yeah because rich folks can afford
better lawyers that's a big reason as to
why Jay Simpson got off got away with
murder we all know that but also it's
interesting how like there's two justice
systems one dealing with rich people and
one dealing with poor people is also two
systems with which we assess like guilt
upon people one in public domain and one
in the actual justice system and I feel
like the public is already sort of
convicted Kevin Spacey even though he
hasn't been convicted in an actual
courtroom and that's something that
we've seen for many of these me two
accusations
sometimes rightfully and sometimes
wrongfully yeah and in this particular
case Kevin Spacey has taken the position
that he doesn't remember this alleged
incident but he apologizes to the extent
that
like any of his actions made the
individual feel uncomfortable and I
don't know also how we rank that I mean
in different situations you see
different types of denials and these
celebrities sort of me to type cases and
honestly I don't know if that's even
relevant to our analysis here of the way
in which the case fell apart because as
far as I know Pat we don't really know
why the alleged victim stopped
participating in this particular case
nor why he decided to delete text
messages I think he claimed he lost the
phone too so naturally the case is going
to fall apart after that yeah but it's
not like this was the only allegation
made against Spacey the initial one was
came from actor Anthony Rapp who said
that Spacey climbed on top of him while
he was in bed in rap was only 14 years
old at the time spacey was 26 at the
time base he says that he doesn't
remember that incident - but that was
like the initial news about him that
broke tying him to the me - scandal and
at that time Kevin Spacey came out and
said that he was gay as a way it is sort
of like distract from the accusation
which everyone just thought was bizarre
and totally uncalled for
yeah and I think that it was actually I
mean it's really unfortunate that he
would do that because we've talked
before about how there's this completely
unfair and baseless sort of idea that
floats out there that homosexuality and
child sex assault or that homosexuality
and sexual predation are in some way
linked or related and of course they're
not and it was particularly sort of
disappointing from the point of view of
LGBT rights and fighting that stereotype
for Kevin Spacey
- almost I mean I don't know that I
would call it a defense but to
simultaneously deny the allegations and
publicly say that he is a gay man is
that well nobody really cares what
people care about is whether your
actions were coercive or predatory your
sexual orientation is wholly irrelevant
to this entire thing yeah I was
tone-deaf at the very least maybe he was
trying to garner some sort of sympathy
from people yeah I were just distracted
to change the news cycle so that the
story of that day is Kevin Spacey comes
out as gay not Kevin Spacey accused of
sexual assault right
after seeing this story I rewatched the
the video that Kevin Spacey put out
about six months ago of him in character
as Frank Underwood and it's just creepy
you see Kevin Spacey in character
denying the allegations looking at the
camera breaking the the fourth wall I
would recommend rewatching that because
it kind of gave me the chills I don't
know if you've seen that it was
extremely creepy I did see it and his
lawyer right after that said no more
videos absolutely no no more videos I
think he also at one point got pizza for
paparazzi that were following him around
after the allegations and that was also
filming just a lot of weird behavior I
don't know so that's where it is now we
may never hear about this again or there
may be other accusers who are going to
be coming forward we don't know there's
this app that has become instantly viral
called face app and what it does is
it'll apply a filter to your face and
make you look aged and some of them are
very very disturbing and unfortunately
it is now increasingly clear that this
is an app which is not only Russia based
but may be harvesting metadata and
photographic data that goes to and is
made available to who knows who Chuck
Schumer issuing a warning about this if
you used face app it's owned by a Russia
based company users are required to
provide full irrevocable access to their
personal photos and data so I have not
downloaded the app Pat you did download
the app I did download the app I saw on
Facebook a bunch of people over the past
few days doing this using the face app
generating old pictures of themselves
and I didn't realize it was a Russian
based company putting out the app I
didn't know they were sketchy ties to it
so I just kind of went along with it we
can actually put up right now an image
of me generated as an old man and I have
to say it looked pretty good for my age
here I still have all my hair that I was
I was very worried about I didn't know
if it was going to make me become bald
but no I think I'm pretty happy with
this I'm I'm okay with living to an old
age because I'm okay with how I look
there but yeah I don't think I would
have done it had I known about the
sketchy
and maybe maybe it's overblown to some
extent but if you just don't know maybe
it's best to play it safe yeah now that
you we have the picture we're obviously
gonna put it up on the screen and in
looking at it so it sort of seems like
you're obviously there's wrinkles that
have been added it seems like your face
has been made sort of thicker or fuller
in some way I guess sort of like the
idea is it goes along with maybe some
weight gain that many people experience
later in life the hair is completely
white now one of the most disturbing
elements of this picture is you seem to
not be wearing a shirt was that
necessary for the picture well I didn't
know at the time that this was going to
be broadcasted in front of a bonus show
audience and I only wanted to do the one
picture and then I deleted the app once
I found out about the sketchy tie so
unfortunately I was not able to take
another one but you know you can only
see my shoulders so I don't think it's
that controversial I don't think it's
the next Pat scandal I think I think
you're gonna be able to weather the
storm on this one a couple years ago
there was a different app that did
something similar which I don't believe
was sort of like Russia connected in
some way and my girlfriend took a
picture of me and then applied an age
filter and what's crazy is the aged
picture of me looked just like my dad I
mean it looks just like my dad today and
it really freaked me out because it made
it seem much more plausible because it's
just like it just looked exactly like my
dad well maybe your dad also used the
app and that app was also made by some
sketchy company maybe from Russia maybe
not and they having your dad's pictures
yeah new to generate your picture to
look like him any any thought on that
that would be extremely dark and I hope
that that's not the case yeah so anyway
I didn't download the app I don't know
heed the warning buyer beware your
mileage may vary apply any of those
different terms to this it is going to
get disgustingly hot in many parts of
the United States here in Boston let me
actually pull up my weather app here in
Boston we are expecting a high of 99 on
Saturday and 99 on Sunday the low only
getting down to 81 on Saturday so I'm
expecting a very very expensive
electrical build this month
for my air-conditioning usage of course
but this is really a health risk to a
lot of different people including older
folks this is we are looking at twenty
to thirty record highs possible Friday
and Saturday ranging from the south
central Rockies
that's like three-quarters of the way
across the United States all the way to
the East Coast there's a global warming
conversation to be had here I just hate
the heat I mean I really don't do well I
don't like it when it's bitterly cold
and when it's in the middle of winter I
say I should really move to Miami Beach
and just be done with it but at the same
time I hate the heat and I really really
suffer through it well are there any
activities that you do to beat the heat
are you just staying indoors all day
enjoying the air conditioning or you try
to get to the beach try to get to a
swimming pool try to do some activities
that make you cool off a little bit I
have a free spot maybe I mean I try to
just do my normal stuff but there's not
that many activities that I really feel
like doing outdoors when it's so hot so
I don't know maybe I'll go we got a
bunch of beaches here in the Boston area
but of course they're gonna be
completely packed I'm gonna show up it's
gonna be crowded I'll have to push my
way into some patch of sand that's going
to be covered in cigarette butts and
cans of who knows what and is it really
worth it is it really I don't know yeah
you know it's gonna be so crowded being
a weekend and being a hundred degrees
yeah maybe it isn't worth it but at the
same time I don't know what I'm gonna do
this weekend it's gonna have to be
something right I can't just just hang
around all day luckily we're in a
position where we don't have to worry
about our health so much I don't think
being both young and also being able to
live in air-conditioned places I think
we're okay but definitely got to heed
the warning if you're older if you don't
live somewhere with air conditioning
it does get dangerous out there and it's
gonna it's probably going to cause many
many deaths across the United States
because this is gonna hit a big portion
of the country yeah France is a place
that is known for not having much air
conditioning and when they have heat
waves they very often do have a number
of elderly deaths as a result of these
heat waves in the United States I mean I
guess as a percentage we probably have
more people who have air conditioning
but a lot of people still don't and
there are parts of the South that
III try to remember which parts they are
but there are parts of the south which
historically tend to have less AC
installation that could really really
suffer during this upcoming heatwave and
I think that there are going to be
cooling centers that people can go to
often in school gyms and places like
that
this is serious I mean this it's not a
hurricane in the same sort of acute
sense but this is serious and people
shouldn't just take for granted that
everything's gonna be fine yeah and
every time that we hear about snow in
April or we hear about record cold
temperatures Republicans Trump they come
out and say that this totally disproves
Goldberg warming I feel like they'll
probably stay silent over the weekend I
don't think they'll have any commentary
on the weather they don't think we're
gonna hear much from them this week idea
so I actually am going to be by the way
I'm going to be going to the beach we
the David Pakman show will be going on
summer vacation for real I know we've
been kidding around about we're taking
four months off because of Pat's
birthday see you around January we're
not doing that but we are going to have
our summer vacation which historically
has often been in August and I am going
to the beach and to give a hint as to
where I'm going I'm going somewhere
where one of the languages they speak
this is so obvious to anybody who knows
one of the languages they speak is
really similar to Spanish I mean if you
speak Spanish you can listen to this
language and just understand it and the
language is not Portuguese the language
is not Portuguese those are the hints
that I'm giving for now am I allowed to
guess or would that not be fair you can
get I haven't heard where you're going
right okay Barcelona I said it's a
language that's so oh wait what oh god
well it's become a lot oh yeah no that's
not what I meant no that's okay fair
enough that's a reasonable guess but
that I'm not where I'm going and also
notice Barcelona is Barcelona on the
beach yeah I guess it is yeah I think
that was a perfectly good guess okay
yeah you know what
my reaction that that was a crazy guess
was wrong but it's what is it it simply
is not where I'm where I'm actually go
I'm actually out of guesses now if it's
not Portuguese and if it's not Catalan I
have no idea maybe you'll never even
tell me where you go on summer vacation
I'll just be left guessing the entire
time I probably won't yeah it's probably
not gonna be anything
talk about okay and certainly not going
to talk about it right now that does it
for today new show new bonus show coming
up tomorrow the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]